eigentlich lernen wir ja dass die welt
natürlich ist alles was wir erleben die
wissenschaft chemie physik und so weiter
unterliegen naturgesetzen aber jetzt
scheint ein albtraum für alle physiker
und physikerinnen weltweit realität zu
werden egal wie verzweifelt sie auch
daran arbeiten die suche nach neuen
zeichen scheitert immer wieder auf ein
neues die physiker und physikerinnen
haben jetzt eine verblüffende
erklärung es gibt keine naturgesetze
sondern alles ist unnatürlich wie bitte
wir leben in einer quasi künstlichen
welt jetzt entwicklungszeiten fix und
herzlich willkommen
30 jahren hatten physiker die idee mit
dem large hadron collider lhc im
schweizerischen genf große sprünge in
der physik fachwelt zu machen ihre
vision der weltweit grösste
teilchenbeschleuniger sollte bei
höheren energien als je zuvor
die eigenschaften der natur noch genauer
untersuchen dabei sollte die entdeckung
neuer revolutionäre elementarteilchen
fast nur noch eine nebensache sein doch
pustekuchen
die ergebnisse des elexis sind bisher
mehr als ernüchternd zumindest auf den
ersten blick alle teilchen die bislang
im teilchenbeschleuniger entdeckt werden
konnten denn die fachwelt bereits aus
dem ich sage es mal profi provozierend
langweiligen wenngleich auch noch nicht
vollständigen standardmodell der
teilchenphysik die entdeckung des higgs
boson im jahr 2012 war lediglich das
letzte teilchen was noch fehlte um das
standardmodell zu vervollständigen
wichtige info das higgs boson ist das
teilchen dass der materie die masse gibt
doch das reicht nicht aus super
symmetrische teilchen neutral - zum
beispiel müssen dringend entdeckt
werden um die bislang aufgestellten
gleichung für vervollständigen und
diese in ihrer natürlichkeit abzurunden
die ergebnislose suche der physikerinnen
und physiker gleicht somit tatsächlich
einer geplatzten sensation so sichert
sich die forscherteams damals auf waren
teilchen der dunklen materie oder
geschwister der explosion zu finden um
so enttäuschter sind die jetzt
tatsächlich konnte keine einzige
voraussage die damals getroffen wurde
wie sehr experimentell bestätigt werden
egal wie fieberhaft auch gesucht wird es
herrscht katerstimmung unter den
physikern und physikerin weltweit das
was sich alle wünschen ist ein
zumindest mal ein kleiner hinweis auf
eine neue physik ein teilchen das nicht
ins standardmodell hinein park quasi
etwas das eine vollständigere theorie
der natur abliefert dabei gab es einige
große freundin momente zum beispiel
noch im dezember 2015 damals zeigte sich
die sogenannte die fotomodelle einen
überschuss an proton paaren in den
daten in mehr als 500 studien suchten
sich die theoretiker unter den physikern
nach ihrer erklärung denn sie
vermuteten dahinter die entdeckung eines
neuen rolle
zur näheren elementarteilchen und sahen
schon eine neue aufregende ära der
teilchenphysik auf sich zukommen heute
wissen die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler dass sie sich dabei wohl
nur um zufällige schwankungen gehandelt
haben muss was für ein cross manche
physikerinnen und physiker vor allem aus
dem theoretischen bereich wählen aber
auch diese diese ergebnisse als ein
aussagekräftiges ergebnis ihr fazit die
gesetze der natur seien eben doch nicht
so natürlich wie man es bisher
angenommen habe um die natürlichkeit
der physik plausibel erklären zu
können müsste man eine art
supersymmetrie nachweisen die theorie
dazu gibt es schon länger doch der
experimentellen beweis
wer wie den blieben uns die physiker
schuldig der theorie nach erhöhen
elementarteilchen der materie die quarks
oder elektronen die masse der
higgs-teilchen dazu müsste ein super
symmetrisches boson existieren das quasi
als überträger teilchen einer
wechselwirkung die hicks masse wiederum
verringert diese theorie der
supersymmetrie liefern im gegensatz zu
anderen erklärungsansätzen der
natürlichkeit einige vorteile und so
glaubte eine ganze physiker und
physikerinnen generation fest an wie
noch in keinem der großen
teilchenbeschleuniger der welt konnten
super symmetrische partner der teilchen
bislang nachgewiesen werden egal mit
welchen energien mannes auch versuchte
stellt euch mal vor den neunzigerjahren
knobel die fachwelt an diese aufgabe
durch die immer höhere beschleunigung
hat sich auch die kluft vergrößern
zwischen den hypothetischen super
partnern und den bereits bekannten
teilchen viele physikerinnen und
physiker glauben deswegen dass sich der
einfluss der teilchen und ihrer super
partner auch das higgs boson nicht
länger ausgleichen können da die
supersymmetrie stark gebrochen zwei
andere forscherteams vor allem aus dem
bereich der experimentalphysik haben den
letzten funken hoffnung noch nicht
verloren und weigern sich standhaft die
supersymmetrie jetzt aufzugeben die
modelle und varianten dieser theorie
sein so individuell dass sich teilchen
auf unerwartete weise verbergen könnten
die suche muss deswegen weitergehend
sagen wie und an einer höchst
spannenden datenlage dies noch zu
analysieren die fehler
dank sicher nicht das lager der
fünfziger und sicheren ist gespalten
die entdeckung bleiben aus und die krise
verschafft sich die theoretiker und
theoretikerin unter ihnen haben sich
mittlerweile damit abgefunden eine
weitere letzte möglichkeit ernsthaft in
betracht zu ziehen
demnach und da haltet euch fest sei die
masse der explosion einfach nicht
natürlich weiter gedacht würde dies
bedeuten dass viele verschiedene
universum mit ganz unterschiedlichen
kombis von falschen matten existieren
würden atome und somit auch lebewesen
könnten jedoch nur in solche universum
mit leichten explosionen entstehen eine
theorie die experimentell wohl niemals
zu belegen ist und somit zu der
nächsten kontroverse in der physik welt
führt denn demnach wäre das toll com
beliebig und in jedem universum an dass
sie das universum wer irgendwie
künstlich zudem beginnen die
theoretischen physiker und physikerinnen
nun damit völlig neue
erklärungsansätze felix matthes gewinn
ganz unabhängig von neuen entdeckungen
die eventuell noch am elektroden
könnten ihrer ansicht nach geht es
jetzt darum das ergebnis 0 am
schweizerischen teilchenbeschleuniger
hinter sich zu lassen und im besten fall
auch zu überwinden eine völlig neue
zeit in der physik ist angebrochen wir
sind gespannt was da kommt ich habe hier
bei klink natürlich auf dem laufenden
wenn ihr kein videos zum thema und zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollte
wird mir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den genau auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter mit matrix sind wir
nur projektionen neue erkenntnisse zum
holografischen universum ein extrem
interessantes video also nicht verpacken
und draufklicken ansonsten bis dann
vielleicht dran